[Applause]
joe biden's road to the white house
may be in hands like these union hands
i voted for joe biden kamala harris how
come
because they're pro labor i've never
watched trump commercial and seen him
mention anything about union labor he
does talk about bringing jobs back
though and supporting manufacturing i
don't believe it
i don't believe a single word he says
luke wanchalk is a welder at the
pennsylvania petrochemicals complex
a massive new shell project announced
during the obama biden years
this would have never happened without
me and us this would have never happened
it's now loudly claimed by president
trump my livelihood is working with my
hands
and i feel like he's giving more
opportunity
to the billionaires to make more off the
working class you know democrats were in
charge
for a lot of years when union membership
nationally was going down
wages weren't going up ceos were making
more and more money don't democrats like
joe biden
share some of the blame for that all
politicians share some of the blame for
that
but it was donald trump who capitalized
he won more union votes nationwide than
any republican presidential candidate
since ronald reagan i am a union
man now joe biden is working to reverse
that slide
but in march the former vice president
appeared to say he wanted to ban
fracking
no new frackie although the campaign
quickly clarified its position
president trump has used the issue as a
weapon in gas rich pennsylvania
over 600 thousand pennsylvanians jobs
gone
how important is natural gas to
allegheny county it's huge
rich fitzgerald is a biden supporter and
the top elected official in allegheny
county
joe biden wants to be carbon zero
on electricity in this country by 2035.
how do you get to
zero carbon by 2035 and still have this
around
because you have carbon capture and you
have technologies that are improving
the production of not only the carbon by
the way
much less carbon uh because of natural
gas yeah much
less than coal and oil that's why they
say it's a bridge but if i'm working
here i'm wondering a bridge to what am i
going to have a job in 15 years
no there'll be more jobs because we're
going to invest also in green
technologies
we need to run our daily lives but it
can be done safer
because we just can't ignore what's
going on in the climate
and joe biden gets that but around here
the economy
often matters most at a small machine
shop in meadville pennsylvania owner
tara heffern says the president
understands people like her
what always attracted me was he was a
businessman
you know my grandfather started out as
an apprentice
and he and a couple co-workers started
out in their basements
slowly pulled themselves up by the
bootstraps trump resonates with me
because
you know look at all the businesses and
everything he built
next we headed to erie county a former
obama county
that trump won by all but guaranteeing a
blue-collar renaissance
four years later it simply hasn't
arrived
erie county today has fewer
manufacturing jobs than when president
trump took
office and that was true even before the
pandemic
but that doesn't mean he's lost the
county or the state
we met cody swartworth at a gas station
in the tiny town of mckeen pennsylvania
he's planning a first-time vote for
president trump
for reasons beyond jobs most of the
people that
don't like them they're
he's doing what he wants to do and what
should be done
all the people that don't want him are
scared
scared of what other people think